Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus ich freue mich heute total
mit dir zu reden weißt du warum weil ich
ich habe mir überlegt ich will heute mit
dir über Sprache sprechen ja okay also
Sprache und zwar mit jemandem der so
sprachgewaltig ist wie du und ich sag
dir warum mir das so ein Bedürfnis ist
unser Kater
hat mir neulich versucht mitzuteilen
dass er gerne Thunfisch essen möchte ja
und er hat es irgendwie geschafft er hat
mir irgendwie vermittelt ich hätte gerne
Thunfische stand so vor mir und hat so
gemeint und mir Haut und so und ich ich
liebe den heiß und ihn nicht und ich
habe irgendwie meine ich verstanden
zweimal wollte Thunfisch und dann hat er
angefangen zu essen aber nicht so
richtig hat so ein bisschen gefressen
aber so eher so so ja dachte ich
vielleicht habe ich ihn nicht richtig
verstanden
das heißt der Kater und ich hatten eine
etwas holprige Kommunikation ja und da
kam mir dieser Gedanke wie faszinierend
ist eigentlich wirklich ist dass wir
Menschen miteinander sprechen können
dass wir uns mitteilen können dass
Kinder uns sagen können wo es ihn weh
tut was das Problem ist und das Sprache
eigentlich nicht nur das ist was uns von
Tieren unterscheidet sondern das Sprache
etwas unvorstellbar großartig ist ja was
ein so wichtiger Teil unserer Identität
ist absolut weil Sprache produziert ja
nicht nur einen Reichtum an äußerer Welt
also dass er mit jedem reden können
genau sondern auch ein gigantischen
Reichtum mein innerer Welt richtig das
heißt wir finden Worte mit denen wir uns
vor uns selbst formulieren können
es gibt eine ganz tolle Beobachtung von
Wittgenstein aus seiner Spätwerk und da
geht es um das Wort hoffen und er sagt
hoffen ist nicht etwas was ein Kind in
sich vorfindet also es gibt sozusagen
keine Biologie des hoffen ja es gibt ja
Leitung im Gehirn weil dann würde man
sich ja sagen wieso können zweijährige
nicht hoffen und wieso können erst
siebenjährige oder so hoffen ja sonst
ist gar nichts biologisch es gibt kein
offen in dem Sinne es gibt aber das Wort
hoffen
und wenn das Kind das Wort hoffen zum
ersten Mal verstanden hat und selbst
benutzt dann geht es von nun an davon
aus dass es oft
ja das heißt also etwas völlig
undeutliches nebliges richtig von Natur
aus gar nicht definiert ist kriegt
überhaupt eine Form ja es wird überhaupt
zu etwas was einem zur Verfügung steht
und deswegen stimmt auch dieser
wittgensteinsatz die Grenzen meiner
Sprache sind die Grenzen meiner Welt
super schön ich ich halte dagegen ich
weiß nicht immer wovon ich rede aber ich
weiß dass ich immer recht habe ja
Mohammed Ali ja auch ganz großer weit
unterschätzt dafür nur so finde ich auch
genau
als Motto drüber
okay viel Spaß jetzt bei dem was dann
daraufhin erst vorher und Mark Twain
auch den liebe ich ja heißt und den ich
auch so ein großer Meister der Sprache
ja ja der der hatte immer die Idee
Deutsch sollte zu den toten Sprachen
dazu gezählt werden weil nur tote die
Zeit hätten sie zu lernen ja ich denke
was für ein Glück dass ich Deutsch nicht
habe als Fremdsprache lernen müssen so
und jetzt machst du das was wir immer
machen wir reden immer so schlecht
Richard über unsere Sprache deutsche
Sprache schwere Sprache und so weiter
findest du nicht dass Deutsch ein sehr
seltsames bescheuertes Image hat und wir
wir reden uns das selber so ein dass
unsere Sprache so eine so eine
komplizierte mühsame Sprache ist und
dadurch befördern wir eigentlich dieses
Gefühl er versucht erst gar nicht weil
deutsch ist so unfassbar kompliziert
aber eigentlich nur gesagt was für ein
Glück ich bin nicht so wahnsinnig gut in
Fremdsprachen bist du nicht love also
jetzt überhaupt nicht
überdurchschnittlich also ich habe eine
Schwester die spricht mehr als zehn
Sprachen ja doch aber jetzt einfach
einfach durch aufsaugen assimilieren ne
also die waren in ihrem Leben an
Marokkaner zusammen dann kam sie zurück
und konnte ziemlich gut arabisch und
auch mal mit dem Befinden zusammen und
konnte Finish also wir sind gerade die
einfachen Sprachen ja und hat auch so
eine Aussprache dass man immer denkt
schon ewig in Finnland gelebt und das
geht ihr mit eigentlich mit Sprachen das
wächst ihr so zu ja also das ist so wie
so Melodie es gibt ja Leute die hören
einmal eine Melodie können die
nachsingen es gibt andere Leute ein
bisschen 30 Mal hören und kriegen es
immer noch nicht hin und so ähnlich ist
das ja auch so mit diesem Gefühl was man
für Sprachen hat also meine meine
Schwester ist ohnehin komplett zwei
Sprachen die ist als deutsche Lehrerin
in Dänemark unterrichtet auf Dänisch und
die hat diese diesen Hang und wenn ich
das sehe kann ich nicht mich nicht als
Sprache begabt behaupten ich brauche
eine Grammatik und ich muss mir das dann
so langsam logisch erstmal überlegen und
so also ich wachse nicht in eine Sprache
rein das beherrsche ich nicht und ich
bewundere das bei Menschen bei denen das
so ist aber trotzdem Deutschland ne und
hatte immer so ein bisschen mit seiner
Sprache und ich finde unsere Sprache ist
eine wunderbare Sprache gibt ich glaube
5 Millionen Wortschatz im Deutschen so
viel wie in wenigen anderen Sprachen
Chinesisch vielleicht noch ja
möglicherweise mein Chinesisch ist
übersichtlich gut aber das was es mal
war
die die die die Eckzahn Eckdaten ja also
5 Millionen ungefähr sprach
Schatz ja fünf Minuten enorm viel was
damit zu tun hat dass du jede
Wortkombination einfach bilden kannst ja
du kannst beliebig Wörter zusammenbauen
und werde kennen das das kannst du
sozusagen bis bis in die Unendlichkeit
betreiben
genau und so eine lego-sprache damit
eigentlich auf eine Art und Weise auch
sehr logisch ja so 103 Millionen
Menschen sprechen Deutsch als
Muttersprache ja 15 Millionen Menschen
lernen in deutsch im Ausland ja 280
Millionen also fast 300 Millionen
weltweit haben in irgendeiner Form
Deutsch gelernt oder sprechendes ja ja
und ich finde das ist erstmal eine
Erfolgsgeschichte und das steht
sozusagen in einem krassen Gegensatz zum
Image dass dieses Tor wenn wir über
Migration sprechen wenn wir sagen wir
brauchen schlaue Leute die jetzt kommen
und jetzt unsere digitale Revolution
vorantreiben dann ist das erste Argument
was ich immer höre ja aber deutsch ist
so eine schwierige Sprache wir sind so
unattraktiv für diese Leute und dann
noch das deutsche Wetter und dann sagt
okay kommen gute Nacht lass uns einfach
aufgeben es hat alles keinen Sinn aber
das ist nicht so und ich habe dieser
Tage über einen wunderbares Buch gelesen
von Roland kehlbrand den du
wahrscheinlich kennst
Sprachwissenschaftler der einen einen
Bestseller gemacht hat über Deutsch eine
Liebeserklärung ja und sozusagen davon
schwärmt wie schön diese deutsche
Sprache ist und wie vielfältig sie ist
und es gibt darin einen total schönes
Beispiel der Satz ich habe sie gestern
am Bahnsteig gesehen ja seitdem kann man
im deutschen und da siehst du wie reicht
diese Sprache ist je nachdem welches
Wort du betonst hat es immer eine andere
Bedeutung dieser einfache Satz
ich habe sie gestern am Bahnsteig
gesehen ich habe sie gestern am
Bahnsteig gesehen ich habe sie gestern
am Bahnsteig gesehen ich habe sie
gestern am Bahnsteig gesehen ich habe
sie gestern gesehen ich habe sie gestern
am Bahnsteig gesehen genau
da siehst du was da alles drin ist ist
doch fantastisch ja ist großartig und
weil das so ist gibt es wahrscheinlich
keine Sprache auf der Welt jedenfalls
der westlich westlichen Kulturkreises in
der man so gut philosophieren kann wie
auf Deutsch so ein großer vorrichter
mein großer Vorteil es gibt ja auch
viele Begriffe der deutschen Philosophie
die in andere Sprachen übergegangen sind
weil man sie nicht übersetzen kann weil
andere Sprachen diese Bedeutung gar
nicht kennen
also der Weltgeist Begriff von Hegel ja
zum Beispiel ja das kann man nicht in
irgendeiner Form auf Englisch oder
übersetzen ohne Blödsinn zu produzieren
ja auch den Weltschmerz übrigens nicht
den ganzen heiliger kann man eigentlich
nicht auf Englisch übersetzen er ist
bestimmt übersetzt es muss lustig sein
das zu lesen weil Heidecker hat ja die
Philosophie im 24 jahrhundert dadurch
neu erfunden indem man nämlich genau
gezeigt hat was man mit dem lego-kasten
alles machen kann super na du kannst
also Begriffe Silben hin und herschieben
wie beim Zauberwürfel ja also das glaube
ich der richtige Vergleich also heiliger
hat sozusagen den philosophischen
Zauberwürfel erfunden ja was man alles
an das Wort sein daran hängen kann und
wo man diese Silbe seinerseits wieder
dranhängen kann und so weiter ich meine
die Deutschen sind das glaube ich das
einzige Volk das sein da sein und so
sein und unterscheide
also dass man sowas überhaupt kann das
kommt nicht von heiliger das war schon
vorher da sein da sein ja
ja also dein so sein hat ja was mit
deiner Individualität zu tun und mit das
da sein ist das Existieren richtig ne
und man kann sagen dein Sein formt sich
ja aus dem Dasein und aus dem so sein ja
herrlich er ist doch schön ja deswegen
meine ich also diese du kennst Georg
Christoph Lichtenberg diesen diesen
schönen Spruch in Deutschland lernt man
das Nase rumpfen noch vor dem Nase
putzen oh ja ja ist auch eine Menge dran
und das auch in Bezug auf die Sprache
wir machen das ist keine schlaue Werbung
ja den das stimmt ne ganz wenige wählen
nur noch irgendwie Deutsch als Schulfach
warum ja oder wenn man sich überlegt ich
meine durch das Alltags den Englisch mit
dem man so konfrontiert ist ne also ich
war gestern im Zug meine ich in der
kriminade sondern wenn ich nicht in der
kriminator bin ich im Zug und da waren
junge Leute die ganz spannendes Projekt
macht das richtig so einen halben Ohr
mit dem Speisewagen und man konnte lange
rätseln was die Sprache war ja in der
sie sich unterhält nicht und die Leute
hatten irgendwas mit Klima zu tun macht
irgendein ganz tolles Projekt aber 50%
der Redewendungen und so weiter war also
Englisch oder Englisch ja war das dann
so 20 so Sätze wie du das finde ich
total nice ja total nice war dabei aber
auch also ich kann es nicht imitieren ja
weil ich ja nicht organisch in andere
Sprachen reinwachse ja also ich könnte
die Melodie nicht nachsummen aber es war
irgendwas ganz anderes ich will das auch
gar nicht böse beschreiben Arbeit du
ändert sich auch aber ist natürlich so
die englische Sprache ist ja in allem
das Gegenteil zur deutschen Sprache also
Englisch ist die Sprache die die besten
Abkürzungen kennt ne man kann
Sachverhalte auf Englisch wahnsinnig
kurz ausdrücken und ich habe mir mal
beibringen lassen wenn man gut Englisch
sprechen will ja also jetzt nicht hoch
Literatur produzieren sondern verstanden
werden will ja und das ist ja im
Deutschen eher anders es ist ja im
Deutschen sogar so dass wir ein Kult aus
Unverständlichkeit und Kompliziertheit
machen es gibt ganze Berufsgruppen die
davon leben dass sie der Dunst der
Unverständlichkeit die bewegt und das
ist einerseits einer Nase putzen ja
einerseits einerseits natürlich
Philosophie wobei man heute sagen muss
der größte Teil der Philosophie in
Deutschland findet auf Englisch statt
ist deswegen gibt's auch ja und deswegen
gibt es auch keinen deutschen heidegang
mehr der ist gar nicht mehr möglich okay
wenn jemand heute wie heiliger schreiben
würde der könnte diese entsprechenden
Fach papers die in den entsprechenden
Journals veröffentlicht werden nicht
schreiben da ist der Aufbau festgelegt
ja das wird im Grunde genommen alles
nach dem Vorbild der Naturwissenschaften
gemacht in einer jüdischen Philosophie
und der Philosophie des Geistes die
Jüngeren Wissenschaftler produzieren da
alle überwiegen englische Texte
und damit ist natürlich dieser ganze
Reich das ist ja nein nein nein das sind
alles Speaker aber die müssen das machen
wenn sie in den angesehenen schon Nein
auf Englisch sind und die Psychologen
sowieso und also in sehr sehr vielen
Wissenschaften ist das inzwischen so und
das natürlich schade weil man auf
Deutsch eben viele Bedeutungen
generieren kann die man den anderen
Sprachen nicht generieren kann also ich
finde es ja großartig wenn man virtuos
auch mit einer anderen Sprache umgehen
kann aber ich finde es genauso schön
wenn man das eben auch mit der eigenen
Sprache macht wenn du kennst ja dieses
Vorurteilen da wollte der der sagte
deutsch spricht man nur mit Pferden ja
dieses Ding deutsch ist so Arsch und so
hart und so das würde ich ganz häufig
dass Leute sagen das klingt so hart und
klar ich meine wenn du italienisch ja
wir haben sehr viel auch italienisch
gesprochen natürlich und es ist ja nur
Vokale ja also die ganze Zeit nur Vokale
und man hat das Gefühl wenn Italiener
mehr als zwei Konsonanten hintereinander
aussprechen muss ja dann verschluckt er
sich oder er stinkt gleich ja und dann
ist das natürlich immer so so so so so
so dieser dieser schöne schöne sing
Sankt der natürlich freundlich klingt
und muss ein bisschen romantisch und so
aber ich finde macht das deutsche hat
dazu Unrecht dieses komische Image also
Roland kehlbrand beschreibt das auch und
sagt im Schnitt sind 13 von 100
gesprochenen Wörtern sind so so
höflichkeitspartikel weißt du so so
Freundlichkeiten so Nettigkeiten zum
Beispiel sollte man zum Beispiel nicht
glauben oder ja nicht in der ganzen Welt
da berühmt dass er der netteste ist so
ja aber seine Sprache ist viel netter
also man denkt so z.B der Satz du hast
es eben gerade selber gemacht sollte man
nicht glauben ne das ist so eine nette
Freundlichkeit drin irgendwie ist nicht
Barsch kann gibst du mir das mal ja was
machen sie dem beruflich ja so dieses
ist so nicht so ganz ja Job oder so ja
Ja
mach halt mach halt die Tür zu ja nicht
anders als macht die Tür zu ja mach halt
die Tür zu das heißt also dieses auch
aber bloß doch eben halt ja schon ja so
das ist alles sehr sehr schön und weil
du gerade diese jungen Leute erwähnt
hast ich muss auch schön kälbbrand weiß
darauf hin und sagt die die eines der
Kernargumente ist oft Heim im englischen
kann man das viel schneller sagen das
ist viel cooler ja so
das geht einfach aber im Deutschen gibt
es das auch geht's noch oder besser ist
als ob er jetzt keine Ahnung ganz kurz
zack zack also know ist deutlich länger
als keine Ahnung außerdem muss man sich
mal die Frage stellen ob die kürzere
Formulierung immer die bessere ist ja
also es ist auch immer so schade wenn
wenn so der Reichtum der Sprache dadurch
verkümmert dass es für eine Sache so
wahnsinnig viel Ausdrücke gibt aber nur
noch am Ende ein englisches Wort dafür
benutzt weil es eben kurz ist und ich
finde es so so weil meine
lieblingsbegriffe nee komm jetzt aus der
bösen Welt ne aber das ist solche
Sprache sehr gut drin ja das Wort
erhältlich für die Haare sehr schön oder
durchtrieben richtig ja und die gibt es
auch meines Erachtens auf gleiche Art
und Weise auch in anderen Sprachen nicht
oder in vielen anderen Sprachen nicht
und das ist natürlich irgendwie Reich ne
wenn man mit diesen mit diesen Worten so
vor sich hin albern kann statt einfach
immer nur die Abkürzung zu wählen das
ist doch wie Mitten gehen ne also man
kann ja sagen wir sind von gehen ist von
A nach B zu kommen aber der deutsche
geht ja auch spazieren
gehen ja bedeutet willkürliche Umwege in
Kauf zu nehmen oder einzuschlagen und da
der deutsche das folgender Spaziergänger
ist ja dann könnte man natürlich auch
genau sagen die deutsche Sprache ist
eher ein Spaziergang als der Versuch von
A nach B zu kommen
also ich finde man sollte die positive
Seite sehen und jetzt wurde ich noch
einen richtigen Joker raus ich glaube
das schon in der Evolution der Sprache
ist nicht darum ging von A nach B zu
kommen
also wir haben ja immer haben wir schon
häufiger darüber geredet so ein
Vorstellung dass Evolution da muss immer
alles zweckdienlich sein richtig und ich
glaube dass mit mit der Sprache da
müssen wir gleich mal länger drüber
reden weil das ein Geheimnis ist ne
niemand weiß woher die Sprache kommt
wann sie angefangen hat und so ja ist
schon wieder Entstehung der Sprache
diese poetische Dimension wahrscheinlich
eine ziemlich hohe Bedeutung hatte das
glaube ich auch das werfe ich jetzt mal
so als these in den Ring also dass sie
nicht rein funktional war von Anfang an
ja weil meine These dazu ist dass
Menschen auch von Anfang an das sehr
interessant wir kommen ja also so die
Idee wir kommen so als tabula rasa zur
Welt ja wir sind einfach irgendjemand
das stimmt nicht sondern ich glaube wir
sind von Anfang an jemand ganz bestimmt
da ja und und das siehst du dann zum
Beispiel Kinder es gibt Kinder die haben
einen unterschiedliches Bedürfnis nach
Romantik
gibt Kinder die finden zum Beispiel den
Mond unglaublich schön das löst bei
denen was aus fasziniert die total
andere wiederum gar nicht ich hatte das
Herz Licht im Advent so ja also dieses
wenn der Adventskranz angezündet wurde
ja also ich wurde sofort metaphysisch
angefasst
wir sind ja sehr selten in die Kirche
gegangen meine Eltern waren ja nicht
religiös aber wir sind Weihnachten in
die Kirche gegangen und ich habe das
geliebt ja ja ich verstehe
diese diese so ein so ein Gefühl
Katholizismus in mir ja also es ist ähm
ich liebe die Kirche wegen des
ästhetischen zenobers ja das ist etwas
es geht mir sofort naja ich kriege
Gefühle in der Kirche und sowas alles
und so ja dabei ist ja der Glaubens
Inhalt ist er eine symbolische Form also
Gott gehört dazu ne das hat doch was mit
Gott zu tun aber die Frage ob Gott jetzt
existiert ist für das Gefühl nicht
wichtig
wichtig ja er könnte auch ein reines
Symbol für etwas sein für die Fähigkeit
zum Guten im Menschen oder für irgendwas
anderes aber dass man überhaupt so so
metaphysisch angefasst wird total das
finde ich großartig deswegen ich bin
sofort bei dir es gibt eine eine
geburtsromantik bei manchen Kindern und
bei anderen gibt es die nicht ja wir
haben so eine also wenn du das gerade
mit der Kirche erzählst ich glaube wir
haben so eine religiöse Begabung ja aber
nicht jeder aber es gibt auch religiösen
erstmal eine wichtige voraus aber ich
bin ziemlich sicher dass in der
Geschichte der Krebs will auch sehr
viele hoch unbegabte Amerika
hochbegabt waren da bin ich aber ich
glaube dieser Papst der ist religiös
hochbegabt glaube ich auch Ratzinger
aber auch religius hochbegabt definitiv
JA aber das Thema
ein anderes Thema aber dieses ich meine
okay die diese Wirkung in der Kirche ich
weiß auch nicht ich habe sehr viel Zeit
weihrauchfässern so verbracht und
Weihrauch ist ein interessantes Kraut
das muss man mal sagen weiß ja gar kein
Kraut sondern
das anzündest
zurück zum Ursprung der Sprache so also
früher dachte man ja es ist übrigens
interessant wie bei all diesen Palio
anthropologischen Fragen ja also all die
Fragen nach unserer Herkunft und so
weiter dass immer der Generation von
Wissenschaftlern da ist die glaubt jetzt
haben wir es rausgefunden ja und jetzt
brauchen wir eigentlich nicht mehr viel
finden weil wir wissen es jetzt und
inzwischen weiß man eigentlich nur noch
dass man fast nichts mehr weiß wenn man
ganz ehrlich ist also man diese klaren
Abstammungslinien die man früher so ein
Biologiebuch hatte ja australopitikus ja
zwei Arten robustus und afrikanus so und
dann kommt Homo habilis und dann kommt
der Heidelberg Mensch und dann kommt der
Neandertaler und dann kommt jetzt so
eine Linie kann heute keiner mehrmalen
und was leider auch bei draufgegangen
ist obwohl er der arme ja ist jetzt vor
einem Jahr gestorben im hohen Alter
Philipp lieber Mensch meinte das Rätsel
gelöst zu haben Ende der 60er Anfang der
70er Jahre warum Menschen sprechen
können und einfach nicht
und es ist und das interessant es ist
immer die Thesen die von
Wissenschaftlern aufgestellt haben sagen
immer mehr über die Wissenschaftler als
über die Wirklichkeit der Mann war
eigentlich Ingenieur Ingenieur okay so
also hat er das als ingenieursproblem
angegangen hat sich genau den Rachen
angeguckt und hat festgestellt beim
Menschen rutscht vom Säuglingsalter bis
zur Fähigkeit zu sprechen die Zunge
allmählich tiefer und der Kehlkopf auf
ja und weil das so ist können wir ja
laut besser artikulieren und das können
halt Schimpansen nicht und so haben das
Kinder steht das wahrscheinlich heute
noch im bio-buch
ist vermutlich falsch ja weil also man
hat ja jetzt mal heute kann man ja mit
mit den tollsten Simulationen und
Computermodell hier und so weiter und es
bleibt dann von all dem was angeblich
Affen nicht können nur noch ein einziger
Vokal übrig das ist das i affen können
kein i wer ist das so Kehlkopfes also
etwas stimmt schon ne mit dem Kehlkopf
dieser Veränderung das stimmt aber Affen
wären rein von artikulationsvermögen bis
auf das i in der Lage die Menschen zu
sprechen das heißt sie könnten beim
Glücksrad auch mal eh kaufen aber keine
aber gut das ist das jetzt das ist jetzt
der gegenwärtige Stand der Forschung
super also lieber Mann als er letztes
Jahr Schlaf war noch Überzeugung die
können doch ganz viel mehr nicht ja weil
er immer darauf hingewiesen hat also
wenn die Affen das alles können warum
tun sie es dann nicht ne und das ist
dann die spannende Frage wenn man sich
sagt irgendwie war das in der affenwelt
irgendwie ja nicht notwendig kann man ja
gar nicht sagen sondern Frage stellte
sich offensichtlich nicht und die andere
Frage ist dann warum hat sich unseren
Vormenschen die Frage gestellt also
warum hat sich das entwickelt ja das ist
ich meine Richard Wember mal also
gedanklich ne und das ist ja das was wir
können nicht ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
Tiere sozusagen in der Lage sind sich
Dinge vorzustellen das ist glaube ich
eines der ganz großen Dinge über die wir
Menschen verfügen die Vorstellung davon
können du siehst doch wenn ein Hund er
liegt und träumt ja dann merkt der
Schritte der sich plötzlich oder knurrt
oder so also Träume hat er schon meinst
du oder
Träume haben den großen Vorteil kommen
ja meistens ohne Worte aus also Hunde
können sich mit Sicherheit komplexe
Bilderwelten vorstellen meinst du ja da
bin ich ziemlich sicher ich glaube dass
die träumen oder dass sie auch an Dinge
denken können an eine Wurst eine Wurst
ohne jeden Zweifel also eine Wurst die
nicht da ist können Sie sich vorstellen
klar und er hat ihn vermisst und
deswegen hat er mir mitgeteilt was auf
ich hätte jetzt aber gerne was davon es
richtig aber sie können sich natürlich
die Dinge für die sie keine Worte haben
nicht vorstellen da sind wir wieder bei
dem was ich am Anfang erzählt habe über
das offen
ja hoffen ist nicht eine Fähigkeit die
sich irgendwann in einem bestimmten
Alter in einem Kind entwickelt ja so wie
sagen kann irgendwann entwickrisse Haare
und ein Axel nur so ja das wächst dir so
zu ja sondern hoffen ist ein Wort das
einem hilft einen bestimmten
Gefühlszustand in eine Bahn zu gießen
und wenn je mehr Worte wir haben ja umso
kompliziertere labyrinente können wir
damit anlegen und damit wächst dieser
Reichtum man innerer Welt er ist
spannend also wir hoffen nicht wenn wir
das Wort hoffentlich kennen
wir fühlen zwar irgendwas aber es ist
nicht eins zu eins hoffen
ich meine die Anfänge geht dir das auch
so ich ich denke ab und zu mal so über
die Anfänge nach also es wäre doch so
spannend ne wenn du jetzt mal du
könntest irgendwie ein paar Millionen
Jahre zurückgehen wo wären wir dann dann
werden wir irgendwo in der afrikanischen
Savanne also jetzt die Frage mal wie
weit zurück der Liebermann dachte ja ne
Homo sapiens konnte sprechen und
Neandertaler ging sogar also er dachte
der die anderen Taler konnte
zumindestens singen hatte mal eingeräumt
ne weil geht ohne i
haha
und und
dafür braucht man sozusagen oder die
Hälfte der Artikulationsfähigkeit ne
oder so lalala vor sich hin trällern das
hätte er wahrscheinlich hingekriegt und
dann hat er irgendwann doch einräumen
müssen das wahrscheinlich auch schon so
Homo erectus und Homo habilis in
irgendeiner Form miteinander gesprochen
habe jetzt sind wir aber schon so 1,5
bis 2 Millionen Jahre zurück also viel
viel tiefer genau ich gehe noch weiter
zurück also ich würde jetzt zurückgehen
harari ja sechs Millionen Jahre stell
dir vor also am aller nächsten stehen
uns ja du bist der Zoologe von uns
beiden Schimpansen Schimpansen und
Bonobos das sind das sind die die
genetisch am nächsten und uns dran sind
ja genau also und zwar gleich weit
entfernt wie viel wie viel Prozent
unterscheiden wir uns das wenn man das
so sicher wüsste ne da gibt's so viele
Berechnungen also die Zahlen gehen so
zwischen 1 bis 1,5% genetische
Unterschied so wenig und 0,5 bis 0,6
noch mal zwischen Schimpanse und Bonobo
also die sind sich sozusagen doppelt so
ähnlich wie Menschen Schimpansen und
ohne Brust aber das ist natürlich sehr
wenig die Zahl ist ziemlich klein ist
krass aber geh mal 6 Millionen Jahre
zurück vor gerade mal 6 Millionen Jahren
ja bringt jetzt irgendwo in der
ostafrikanischen salamanne bringt eine
errin auf dem Bäume noch also 6
Millionen Jahre zurück ja also ich schon
klar aber du kannst keine Savanne
sondern wirklich mit
also es ist Wald es ist waldkana war
noch da um ihn abzuholzen werden keine
Zeit dazu hat auch keiner gemacht keine
Werkzeuge kein Bock so vor sechs
Millionen Jahren bringt also eine
Erfindung zwei Töchter zur Welt eine der
beiden wird die Urahnen aller
Schimpansen und die andere ist unsere
Ururgroßmutter so muss es doch gewesen
sein
gute Frage also würde man das im
Kinderbuch aufmachen ja ja ich das ist
spannende Frage so wird die Frage ja
selten gestellt ja irgendwann muss ich
was verzweigt haben so ja ja und und die
Frage warum was ist dann passiert ich
meine warum warum hat sich dann
plötzlich bei unserer
Ururgroßmutter Schimpansen dieses Gehirn
entwickelt genau also jetzt gab es dafür
ja immer Erklärung von dem wir heute
alle wissen dass sie falsch sind ja aber
die meisten die uns zuhören in der
Schule immer noch lernen ja
weißt du es wird ja alles immer
rätselhafter und irgendwas muss man ja
lernen früher hat man dann immer gelernt
vor zwei drei Millionen Jahren setzte
das große Waldsterben ein ja und zwar
weil der ostafrikanische Graben Aufriss
die berühmte Gregory Spalte ich warte
mal die einmal die geht ja ganz lang
also Tausende von Kilometern durch
Afrika durch und an diesem großen
Grabenbruch liegen auch die die Vulkane
und die Berge
ich bin in Tansania gewesen also nicht
ganz so weit davon weg aber jetzt
unmittelbar am Rift Valley war ich nicht
da liegt drin und so also das ist dieser
der ist ganz tief also das ist dieser
Graben das ist der Graben auffrisst
veränderte sich ähm die die
Luftfeuchtigkeit die thematische
Verhältnisse die Wälder ging zurück das
Bieber nur so kleine Insel Wälder übrig
und Savanne breitete sich aus
so diese Geschichte ist auch nicht
umstritten aber man hat dann gesagt so
entstand der Mensch weil er kam
sozusagen aus seiner Komfortzone ja wo
eben die Früchte da vor der Nase hin
raus vom Baum runter musste vom Baum
runter und musste sich irgendwo in der
Savanne zurechtfinden und unter diesem
neuen umweltdruck fing Menschen an
zunehmend aufrecht zu gehen damit sie
besser was Gras gucken konnten klar
manche glauben sogar fing an mit
Zweierbeziehungen und sowas also selbst
alle möglichen tollen Theorien Werkzeug
gebraucht und so das
Anpassungsleistungen an dieser Wanne
Feuer noch nicht kommt Feuer deutlich
später aber weiß nicht so genau wie und
Sprache hat man ja gesagt auch noch sehr
viel Schwerter so das war die bisherige
Theorie an der ist sicher alles falsch
ja okay weil weil das wäre das wäre
entgegen Darwin das wäre Lamarck also
Vererbung erworbene Eigenschaften sich
vorzustellen ja dass Sie gedacht haben
ich muss mich hier immer auf ich kann ja
über das Gras nicht rüber gucken dann
wäre aber gut wenn ich mich mal
anstrenge auf zwei beiden zu laufen und
dann hätte sich die Anstrengung vererbt
und siehe die Kinder können noch besser
auf zwei beiden laufen okay also
widerspricht jeglicher moderner
Evolutionstheorie so kann das gar nicht
gehen und es kann auch nicht sein dass
der der vier Schritte mehr auf zwei
beiden laufen konnte von allen Weibchen
belagert wurde und den ganzen Nachkommen
gezeugt gezeugt hat es ist alles Unsinn
heute dass die ersten aufrecht gehenden
ja jetzt in deine Zeit zurückfallen
diese 6 Millionen Jahre also als ich
Mensch und Schimpanse trennten fingen
die schon an auf den Bäumen Menschen
nannte man die noch nicht aber diese
Vorgänger aufrecht zu gehen was zum
Beispiel gib uns auch mal ganz gerne
machen interessant ja und dass der
aufrecht gegangen überhaupt keine
Anpassungsleistung an dieser Wanne ist
also das weiß man heute ziemlich sicher
und damit fällt natürlich alles weg
außerdem haben wir keine direkten
Abstammungslinien mehr also jedes Jahr
werden irgendwo wird er wieder ein
Schädel gefunden und Knochen und da kann
man wieder mit einer völlig neuen
Theorie hatten richtig also
sollen genau
so lange ja bis man in Simbabwe oder so
was wie wichtig ist ja klar also
deswegen ist das alles wahnsinnig unklar
und ich finde eine andere Ernährung
spannender nämlich die Frage wozu
Sprache wohl mal gut gewesen ist
das finde ich interessant da sagt der
harari vor ficht ja diese etwas
augenzwinkernde these für Klatsch und
Draht ja genau
weil ich mag diese These nicht dass das
so streng funktional war genau ich
glaube ja auch dass die Kunst nicht
dadurch Musik ist nicht dadurch
entstanden dass so wie man sich das
landläufig vorgestellt hat da waren
Knochen in der Höhle und dann haben die
Männer dann rum geschnitzt und da rein
geblasen und siehe da kommen schöne Töne
raus ne dann haben sich vor die Weibchen
gestellt und wollten die Weibchen
bezirzen das ist die dümmste Theorie ich
glaube dass das mit Sicherheit nicht so
war sondern das spielen die Kinder
festgestellt haben wenn man da rein
pustet macht Geräusch also das ist
sozusagen halt die Musik entstanden
weil man damit besser ein Weibchen dran
kam oder irgend so ein Quatsch ne und
die Verspieltheit könnte ja auch der
Grund warum
man kann man kann so so viel machen
damit und ich finde immer werden Jane
goodle als ich sie zuletzt getroffen
habe hat mir erzählt der spannendste
Unterschied zwischen Schimpansen und
Gorillas besteht darin dass Schimpansen
alles was andere tun nachäfft
Gorillas nicht okay so und da wir ja
näher mit den Schimpansen verwandt sind
stelle ich mir das einfach so vor einer
fängt irgendwie aus Blödsinn mit was an
und die anderen machen das und
entwickeln es dadurch weiter und
entwickeln es im Spiel quasi weiter
und bei der Sprache ist das so man
brabbelt man kann ein paar laute man
imitiert laute wenn bestimmter laut mal
sehr häufig gleich imitiert worden ist
kriegt er eine etwas höhere Bedeutung
man identifiziert ihn wieder als der
laut der doch in dem Spiel ja richtig
und das ist dann so ein
sozialen verselbstständigungsprozess
gegeben hat also das was ich jetzt hier
erzähle ich bin ja kein Paleo
Anthropologe
genauso
ja danke danke
nein aber ich glaube dass man oft auf
diese Art und Weise in alternativen
Zugriff darauf hat als ich das alles
immer so strenglisch erklären
das merkst du ja auch bei Kindern wie
sehr Kinder dann so in diesem in diesem
Spiel versinken und so weiter also ich
Dinge vorstellen abtauchen völlig in
Fantasiewelten aber es ist eben die
faszinierende Frage also wenn man sich
das mal anschaut Säugetiere mit einem
Körpergewicht von von weil sie nicht 50
60 Kilo die haben im Schnitt ein Gehirn
Volumen 200 Kubikzentimeter 200 das
Gehirn des Homo sapiens
1200 bis
1400 das heißt wir haben sozusagen ein
wahnsinnig schweres
Gewicht ein großes Gehirn und uns sehr
schnell gewachsen ist diese kurzer Zeit
und seitdem kaum noch weiter wächst und
das ist doch total interessant oder und
und auch also das macht zum Beispiel für
mich evolutionär und eigentlich gar
keinen Sinn also so ein gewaltiges
Gehirn kostet viel Kraft körperlich
schon meine Last das rum zu schleppen
brauchst zum großen Schädel ja deswegen
Energie
das wollte ich gerade sagen also bei uns
macht das das Gehirn zwei bis drei
Prozent des Körpergewichts aus aber ein
paar verbraucht im Ruhezustand
25% der Körper Energie
8%. das heißt da haben etwas im Kopf das
arbeitet die ganze Zeit ja also
das funktioniert
gut war
ja weil es unterm Strich unter diesem
Energie gut ist Entwicklung in die
falsche Richtung und deswegen muss man
anders fragen wie konnte sich das Gehirn
entwickeln obwohl es für nichts gut war
obwohl es sozusagen unter biologischen
Aspekten Schritt in die falsche Richtung
war und wir haben ja schon ein paar mal
festgestellt dass Menschen die sehr
wenig davon besitzen nicht die
unglücklichere Mischung ist das ne genau
also wir haben Hinsicht keinen Sinn so
schlau zu sein zum Beispiel wir
verteilen wir vertreiben uns selbst aus
dem Paradies durch unsere durch unser
Gehirn ja das ist wahrscheinlich der
wahre Sinn dieser biblischen Geschichte
vom Sündenfall wo ist das gleiche Apfel
der Erkenntnis ja führt zum Bösen
erwacht und so war das wahrscheinlich
auch in der in der in der Evolution also
es gibt dann immer die Theorie dass man
gesagt hat ja weil als die Menschen
Feuer machen konnten und das Fleisch
dann gekocht haben können Sie viel mehr
Fleisch essen dann ließ sich auch besser
verkaufen und so wo es Fleisch sehr
schwer zu kauen
und dann haben sie immer mehr Fleisch
gegessen dadurch haben sie mal mehr
Protein zu sich genommen und dadurch
konnte das Gehirn so wachsen so diese
Theorie ist auch nicht so ganz
überzeugend weil dann müssten die
schlausten Tiere die sein die am meisten
Fleisch essen also Raubkatzen zum
Beispiel ja sind nicht so sehr schlau
mein Kater schon also der ist okay es
Raubtier ist sehr sehr schlimm wie
gesagt der kann mir mitteilen dass er
Thunfisch möchte also insofern etwas
drauf
nein also das Fleisch essen alleine ist
es natürlich nicht richtig ist aber ohne
Proteine wäre es nicht gegangen im
Gesicht so dass man die Erklärung ja
andersrum aufziehen muss also es gibt
einen anderen Grund offensichtlich warum
sich das Gehirn so entwickelt hat und
das günstig günstige Umstand dass man
mehr Fleisch essen konnte ja hat er die
Hardware dafür geliefert okay also so
wäre es eine sinnvolle Erklärung
aber was war das andere was war das
andere richtig und wie hat sie Sprache
entwickelt ich meine vielleicht näher
uns mal andersrum also du sagst oder
mein Kater kann ja sprechen haben ja
festgestellt ja so Tiere können
grundsätzlich sprechen es gibt also
kommunizieren sagt man mal es gibt es
gibt hier die die
grünmeerkatzen ja zum Beispiel
die warnen sich gegenseitig mit
unterschiedlichen schreien vorgefahren
ja je nachdem ob die Gefahr vom Boden
kommt die Schlange ja oder ob es der
Leopard ist der der Adler ist oder der
Kronen Adler richtig das ist ja total
interessant es gibt ja ein Experiment
dazu du kennst das bestimmt ich kannte
das nicht aber es ist total interessant
also je nachdem welchen laut aus ihrer
Sprache sagen wir es jetzt mal du an der
grünen mehr Katze vorspielst wird sie
sich entsprechend verhalten also wenn du
wenn du ihr das Geräusch vorspielst dass
sie macht wenn man sich gegenseitig vor
dem Adler wart dann gucken die ängstlich
in die Luft ja und runter und runter vom
Baum richtig unter der kann nicht durchs
fliegen jedenfalls ist es schwierig
genau also du fliest nach unten richtig
ja wenn du ihr vorspielst was sozusagen
das Geräusch das gemacht wird wenn sich
der Leoparden hier hat fließt du nach
oben
genau was bedeutet die verstehen sehr
wohl unterschiedliche laute und ich
glaube auch bei Schimpansen die
kombinieren das auch miteinander und so
weiter und je nachdem was sie machen
heißt es jede immer wieder etwas anderes
also bestimmte Laute kombiniert z.B soll
offenbar bedeuten Unterwerfung ich
akzeptiere dich als den Rang höre also
im Augenblick ist man so dabei bei
Schimpansen so von etwa 400 bis 500
Bedeutungen zu unterscheiden die durch
Zeichensprache die hat noch viel
wichtiger ist ne wir reden ja jemand
über Lautsprache aber durch nonverbale
Kommunikation und durch laute und laut
Kombination erzeugt werden das ist nicht
wenig das jetzt verglichen mit Menschen
mit dem Wortschatz der deutschen Sprache
natürlich viel andererseits glaube ich
gibt es auch genug Menschen die zwar der
Sprache mächtig sind die aber auch mit
400 Bedeutungen
also dass das scheint so das ist ja
augenblickliche Stand der Erkenntnisse
aber es gibt eine Sache die den Menschen
komplett unterscheidet davon
Menschen Formen bedeutungsvolle Wörter
aus bedeutungslosen lauten wenn du das
Wort Käse hast dann hat das keine
Bedeutung keine das Essen nicht und das
eh nicht nichts davon hat irgendeine
Bedeutung
das heißt es gibt eine abstrakte
Bedeutung die aus Bedeutungen
zusammengesetzt sind die für sich
genommen keine Bedeutung hat sondern wir
haben das verabredet einfach fertig zu
sein so weit wir das jedenfalls wissen
das interessant
wo wir auch sagen oh die haben ganz
viele five laute und Gesänge und so
weiter dann geben wir doch nicht davon
aus dass sie bedeutungsvolle Wörter
erzeugen
und die zweite Theorie die es gibt die
geht ja davon aus dass ich sozusagen
Sprache entwickelt um Informationen über
die Umwelt auszutauschen und da geht's
dann also nicht so sehr darum sich was
sie sich dass ich Menschen über Löwen
und Büffel oder was auch immer
unterhalten sondern über ihre eigenen
Artgenossen das was du vorhin kurz
angedeutet hast also Klatsch auch das
glaube ich auch und ich rari schreibt
das auch so herrlich und sagt er soll
die Vorstellung der ist ja Historiker
Geschichtsprofessor in Jerusalem soweit
ich weiß die Vorstellung dass geschichts
Professoren zusammensetzen in der
Kantine und und geistig hochtrabendes
Zeug und und und philosophische Dinge
und und hochintellektuelles Zeug
austauschen ist natürlich Quatsch
sondern die Reden darüber
wer mit wem und was wann und wo und
einfach richtig Klatsch und Tratsch weil
das offenbar ein ja an wie soll man
sagen ein wichtiges Bindemittel unserer
Gesellschaft ist weil wir in Horden
verbinden leben weil wir soziale
Primaten sind weil die größte
Intelligenz Herausforderung im Leben
eines Menschen ja nicht im Zweifelsfall
Quantenphysik oder KI programmieren ist
sondern das was andere denken
weil das ja am Blackbox Charakter hat
naja wir können uns also in der Welt
anderer Menschen ja nur dadurch
zurechtfinden dass wir pausenlos
interpretieren und antizipieren was
andere Menschen denken und uns besonders
interessiert uns natürlich was über uns
denken
und dadurch die dadurch dass wir dieses
soziale Stadt spielen und und
Erwartungen aufbauen und Erwartungen
daran was andere von uns erwarten also
erwartungserwartungen und so weiter und
so weiter dadurch wird natürlich unser
Gehirn viel mehr beansprucht als wenn
ich jetzt eine komplizierte
mathematische Aufgabe löse
ja und deswegen glaube ich auch dass die
die der Motor der der Sprache
Entwicklung und der Gehirnentwicklung im
sozialen Schach lag also das was harrari
Klatsch und tratscht ne mit einem
gewissen Augenzwinkern was ich soziales
schaffen nennen würde und es ist ja wenn
man also ich weiß ja nicht was andere
Menschen so denken ich kriegst du mit
wenn ich im Zug fahre und jemand
telefoniert
und wenn ich dann gucke worüber
unterhalten die Leute sich dann so dann
werden ist es in der Regel nicht ne also
es geht wenig darum sich in der Umwelt
zurecht zu finden es geht nie um die
Wahrheit
also eine Sache für die also die Sprache
und das Denken überhaupt nicht
geschaffen sind wichtig ja es geht auch
nicht darum sein Wissen über Fakten
massiv zu bereichern ja sondern es geht
tatsächlich in erster Linie ja um
soziale Belanglosigkeiten die aber in
dieser Sekunde wo man sich darüber
unterhält Sozialplan sind richtig ich
ich finde das interessant also wenn du
dir eine Gruppe von 50 Menschen
vorstellst ne dann gibt es dann über
1.200 Beziehungen
ja und eine eine noch viel größere
unüberschaubare Zahl von Dreiecks
Vierecks übers Eck und sonst was
Beziehungen das heißt dieses soziale
Schach dass du da gerade ansprichst ist
natürlich enorm wichtig ne Klatsch und
Tratsch wie es harari nennt wir müssen
verstehen oder versuchen zu dekodieren
was passiert da gerade und wo ist mein
Platz innerhalb dieser Gruppe von diesen
50 Leuten sehr enorm wichtig für uns zu
wissen wer ist tendenziell so wie ich zu
dem fühle ich mich hingezogen zu wem er
nicht ja wie tickt sie wie tickt er und
so weiter dass er alles wichtig um
seinen eigenen Platz zu finden ja
absolut und es sind Variablen keine
konstanten richtig weißt du wenn ich in
der Physik einmal rausgefunden habe ja
aber wie viel Grad Wasser kocht dann
gibt es einem an Sicherheit Grenzen
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es zum nächsten
mal ganz genau so ist also hatte sehr
große Regelhaftigkeit
aber menschliche Gemeinschaften überleg
dir mal du fährst mit der Klasse in
Ferienlager ja und am Anfang gibt es
eine gewisse eintrainierte Form wie wer
sich zu wem verhält ja und dann löst die
sich innerhalb weniger Tage aus weil man
nicht in dem normalen Kontext der Schule
und der Klasse ist sondern dann fängt er
mit der was an und dadurch verändert
sich das und dann ist ja die Freundin
verändern und auf einmal ja
karnevalisiert sich die ganze Gruppe
also so habe ich das jedenfalls
empfunden du kennst das einmal ja also
ich kenne das selber noch eben aus aus
der Schulzeit erfahren Karneval meine
ich jetzt da kennst du das auch ja da
passiert auch das gleiche Leute die sich
nicht kennen irgendwo rein oder am Ende
sind das alles deine Freunde
[Gelächter]
interessant
Neandertaler und und die ersten sapiens
ja waren wahrscheinlich noch nicht so
richtig gut darin hinter vorgehaltene
Hand übereinander zu reden
erst dann als diese Fähigkeit diese
Sprachkompetenz dazu kam der Moderne
Homosapiens vor ungefähr ja 70 80.000
Jahren was willst du sagen
das erste Mal sozusagen möglichst
stundenlang übereinander zu tratschen
und so klatschen und zu labern bis
hinein in die heutige Zeit schönen Gruß
an Frauke Ludowig und auch an die neue
Post ja das ist das ist das ist genau
das brauche ich übrigens wirklich
herzlich grüße Dich war nicht gerne
mochte immer als Kollegah aber das ist
sozusagen der Grund warum sie so lange
so erfolgreich ist ja diese Sendung sind
zwar nicht im Neandertal entstanden ihm
aber gleichwohl immer ästhetisch
verpflichtet und deswegen haben sie auch
so Einschaltquoten sie erinnern uns an
sozusagen an unseren Waren Wesens ja ja
das meine ich das trifft das trifft
total einen Nerv und deswegen lebt eine
ganze Industrie davon so erfolgreich ja
ich meine die ganzen sozialen Netzwerke
sind doch nichts anderes richtig ja also
da kommen wir quasi zur Natur der
Kommunikation zurück
deswegen sind sie wahrscheinlich auch so
eine so eine Droge und und und deswegen
funktionieren sie so gut ich meine das
ist ja auch so und wenn du mal wirklich
überlegst unsere Telefongespräche unsere
E-Mails auch letzten Endes
Zeitungsberichte alles
wir denken wir lesen wenn wir einen gut
gemachten Artikel weil kann ja auch in
der Süddeutschen oder so du liest ein
tolles Stück aber der Einstieg ist doch
ganz häufig szenisch da geht's dann um
um um um um irgendetwas was du dann
wieder beobachtet hast weil keine Ahnung
mitgekriegt hast im regierungsflieger
oder wo auch immer das doch nicht
wirklich wichtig aber es erzählt so viel
und es fasziniert uns ist der Trick zu
dem gute Schreiber greifen ja Klatsch
und Tratsch gewissermaßen um uns erstmal
reinzuziehen und dieses Stück das ist
der Trick mit dem Sie uns dass die
Karotte die sie uns hinhalten die die
Verführung genau
ja oder funktioniert was wir jetzt
natürlich nicht so viel besprochen haben
ist das was ich am Anfang sagte mit
Poesie und Dichtung also wir haben ja
jetzt ganz stark beleuchtet wie wie
sinnvoll und nützlich und sei es auch
für banale Zwecke es war dass man sich
untereinander gut verständigen kann aber
das zweite was eben auch in diesen
Evolutionstheorien oft zu kurz kommt ist
ja das Sprache einem hilft sich auch mit
sich selbst zu verständigen
und dafür da kann das kann die
Sprachentwicklung ja auch voranbringen
also Menschen die in ihrem Kopf sehr
viele Steine bewegen und hin und her
wälzen das hat ja im großen Einfluss auf
ihr Denken und dann wieder ein großes
Einfluss auf ihre Sozialverhalten oder
dass man sprachliche Dinge schön finden
kann
der Sinn für Lyrik ist die Frage ist ja
so alt wie die ersten Gedichte oder war
der vorher schon da und hat sich anders
geäußert
ne dass man also Sachen poetisch findet
dass man sich dann irgendwas entzückt
das wird verschiedene spannende Frage ob
es vielleicht schon Pansen laute gibt
jemand von sich gibt jemand besonders
berührend findet
was sehr sehr schwer das zu erforschen
das kann man nicht so ohne weiteres aber
das finde ich interessant also müsste
ich Jane goodle wenn ich sie noch mal
treffe Nachfragen Fragen hier aber wie
wir alle kennen das doch ich meine wenn
du wenn du bestimmte Gedichte liest
irgendwie wenn du wenn du bestimmte
Texte hörst das manches fasst dich
einfach an du kannst nicht wirklich
begründen warum das so ist das dass du
Lieblings Zeilen lieblingsreime
Lieblingstexte lieblingssprachbilder die
das ist so viel dass es mir dann immer
schwer fällt das richtige oder passende
auszuwählen ist ja auch irgendwie eine
Frage der Stimmung es gibt den Gedicht
von Robert Frost des Waldes dunkel sieht
mich an doch muss ich zum versprechen
stehen und Meilen gehen bevor ich
schlafen kann super das ist zum Beispiel
was was mir immer wenn ich durch den
dunklen Tannen gehe einfällt und ich
räume die Übersetzung Leistung weil das
heißt im Original the woods and darkly
dance and deep but I have promises to
keep and mile
sleep and miles to go beforeise lieb so
und die Pointe ist im englischen sind es
ja zwei Paar Reime und der deutsche
Übersetzer hat einen schließenden Reim
daraus gemacht richtig und diese
Leistung das gleiche Gefühl wo er
gemerkt hat wenn ich das einfach
übersetze stellt sich das nicht ein
durch eine Veränderung hervorzuführen
finde ich beeindruckend der ist super so
das ist sowas das kann man so monoton
ewig vor sich her sagen ja wenn man in
der Natur ist weil das ist zum Beispiel
wir haben ja sehr viel über Natur
Erlebnisse geredet am Anfang hat man
noch einen voll gequatschten Kopf und
dann reduziert sich das immer weiter und
die letzte Stufe vor dem man nichts
denken das ist für mich immer diese
Roboter das stimmt ja bei mir sind bei
mir ist es eher so so so so Goethe ja
über allen Wipfeln Herr Stroh und mir
fallen auch schon die Augen zu so wie
das dann immer um gedichtet das war ja
so unsere Art uns aber noch mal
sprachlicher der Sinn von Sprache ja das
was uns von Tieren wirklich dann
unterscheidet
da jemand wie harari der zum Beispiel
sagt dass wirklich einmalige Ansprache
ist nicht dass wir Informationen über
Menschen und lösen und ja
austauschen können die uns
möglicherweise bedrohen sondern das
wirklich einmalige ist dass wir uns über
Dinge austauschen können die es gar
nicht gibt ja und nur wir Menschen sind
wirklich dazu in der Lage ja wir können
dann sagen der Löwe ist was was ich der
der Schutzgeist unseres Stammes ja und
er sagt halt sehr schön sagt denn nur
der Mensch kann über etwas sprechen das
gar nicht existiert und noch vor dem
Frühstück sechs unmögliche Dinge glauben
also an den Affen würden sie niemals
dazu bringen in eine Banane abzugeben
indem sie ihm einen affenhimmel ausmalen
und grenzenlose Bananen Schätze nach dem
Tod versprechen und er stellt die schöne
Frage warum lassen wir uns auf diesen
Hand so leichtfertig ein ich meine damit
argumentiert Religion seit Jahrtausenden
und das läuft das Löschen Sie in der
Lage Dinge die es nicht gibt als
mindestens ebenso bedeutend wie nicht
als bedeutender zu erachten als Dinge
die es gibt genau ja das ist ganz
großartig es gibt ja auch Menschen die
Weinen bei sentimentalen Filmen obwohl
sie wissen alles Fiktion richtig die
sind aber so hart Knochen im Alltag dass
sie da nie weinen genau ja es ist oder
Sentimentalitäten Männer werden beim
letzten Mal ja darüber gesprochen über
Kriegserfahrung und so weiter ja und das
waren diese Männer die die ihre Gefühle
nicht gezeigt haben ja aber wenn man den
dann dann das Wolga Lied vorgespielt hat
oder so ja dann schossen ihn die Tränen
in den Augen ja und das Wolga Lied ist
natürlich eine Fiktion ja das ist jetzt
sozusagen etwas was gar kein realer
Gegenstand im Sinne ist im Gegensatz zu
den gefallenen Kameraden und so weiter
man wirklich erlebt hat aber die
Erinnerung an die Kriegs
eben nicht die Tränen in den Augen drei
Takte eines bestimmten Liedes schon ja
ich weiß ich glaube Helmut Schmidt der
war ja ein sehr großer guter
Klavierspieler und der der hat mal auf
die Frage ich so sinngemäß was in so ein
Musik fasziniert gesagt musik ist die
Sprache die all die Dinge sagen kann die
Wörter nicht können und es stimmt ist
auch eine und und so haben wir
offensichtlich im Laufe der Evolution
oft auf diesem langen Weg vom vom Baum
runter ja bis bis hier in die
norddeutsche Tiefebene haben uns
sozusagen ganz viele Formen von von
Sprache überlegt die Art und Weise zu
kommunizieren meine wir haben jetzt noch
gar nicht gesprochen auch über die ganze
nonverbale Kommunikation ne also Sprache
ist ja nicht nur das was wir sagen wir
haben vorhin ja gehört also wie du es
betonst was hast du dabei im Gesicht ist
ist das ein ein freundlicher
Gesichtsausdruck oder wirkst du
aggressiv wie betonst du das wie wie ja
was ist was ist die ganze der ganze
Charakter dabei der mit transportiert
wird all das ist ja Kommunikation und
ich würde sagen nonverbal läuft doch
mindestens genauso viel wie verbal
absolut wir schaffen nur unseren Sinn
nicht so sehr dafür ne also die die die
noch verbalen Dinge nehmen wir ja
meistens viel intuitiver war
weil als Kind natürlich sehr viel
stärker worüber darauf angewiesen sind
und überall da wo wir dann ein festes
Wort für irgendwas gewinnen haben wir
immer das Gefühl wir finden halt
Unsicherheit im Leben dann können wir
etwas einordnen und den Dingen fertig
werden und hier größer die
begriffsmaschine in unserem Kopf ist
umso mehr neigen wir dann dazu die
nonverbalen Signale nicht mehr
wahrzunehmen also ich wage mal die These
dass solche Leute die so komische Berufe
machen wie Philosophen oder so oder oder
Leute die sich die komplette Zahlen
Welten geschaffen haben hochbegabte
Mathematiker und so weiter meistens
nicht legendär dafür sind dass ihre
intuitive Intelligenz bin Aufnehmen von
Körpersprache besonders gut wäre
weil es alles rational läuft sozusagen
ja also alles was wir rationalisieren
ich meine das Leben baut nichts auf wozu
ist die Steine nicht woanders her holt
also wenn du auf dem einen Gebiet
besonders viel aufbaust und er soll
sozusagen wenn sicheren Kosmos zu
schaffen ne dann hast du woanders was
abgebaut was vorher dafür zuständig ja
also wir verschieben ja eigentlich immer
nur
Paul Watzlawick ähm
Villach in Villach geboren nicht weit
von mir zu Hause 1921
österreichischer Psychotherapeut
Philosoph
Kommunikationswissenschaftler
hoch interessanter Mann
begründet ist radikalen Konstruktivismus
der sagt dass alles alle Aussagen über
die Wahrheit relativ zu sehen sind und
zwar abhängig vom Standort des
Betrachters
ja es gibt keine Realität sondern es
gibt immer nur eine Realität die einen
Beobachter beobachtet interessant und
wenn man jetzt wirklich Realität
erfahren wollte dann müsste man sich als
Beobachter ja mit einbeziehen dann
brauchen wir einen Beobachter zweiter
Ordnung den wir uns vorstellen müssen
der uns beobachtet wie wir die
Wirklichkeit beobachten super super und
der hätte dann aber wieder das gleiche
Problem der hätte dann wieder das
gleiche Problem genau spannend der hatte
auch die sozusagen die sein seine
Hauptthese was Sprache angeht wir können
gar nicht nicht kommunizieren wir
kommunizieren immer ja wir reden immer
miteinander wir tauschten
nicht kommunizieren will in einer
Lebensbeziehung und dann die Arme
verschränkt und sich einfach hinsetzt
und sagt ich kommuniziere nicht dann
steckt man ein ganz großes Signal ja ich
will nicht mit dir reden und ich will
nicht mit dir reden ist natürlich ein
kommunikatives Signal das stimmt man
kann nicht nicht kommunizieren völlig
richtig spannend du kennst dein Buch
Anleitung zum unglücklich sein ja war
damals ein ziemlich beste
ich einfach also erstmal er hat sich
viel Witz er hat er hat so ein also er
hat es geschafft Philosophie mit mit
einer ganz großen Leichtigkeit ja super
und Sicherheit und Präzision miteinander
zu kombinieren und ich glaube für diese
Fähigkeit sind Österreicher hochbegabt
ja total weil mein absoluter
Lieblingsschriftsteller Robert Musil
genau die gleiche Kunst beherrscht Mann
ohne Eigenschaft ja also das wahnsinnig
tiefgründiges Buch aber jede einzelne
Satz für sich genommen hat eine gewisse
Leichtfüßigkeit und immer auch etwas
augenzwinkerndes und man wir haben ja
vorhin gesagt die deutsche Sprache ist
ganz besonders geeignet dafür zu
philosophieren aber vielleicht die
österreichische wenn ich sie mal
unterscheiden mag noch ein klein
bisschen mehr
die hat den Hand die eingebauten Hang
zum Weltschmerz genau und aber
gleichzeitig auch eben den Sarkasmus und
die Kunst leicht über schwere Dinge zu
reden und das ist etwas was wir sonst ja
eigentlich immer nur den Engländern
zumuten dass sie so ein schwarzen Humor
haben und so weiter und aus zu den
finstersten Sachen noch ein Witz machen
können oder so total die Österreicher
können das auch viel besser als die
Deutschen ja also vielleicht ist
österreichisch die philosophisch zu
Sprache ja
Engländer sind wirklich also auch wie
die mit Sprache umgehen und was was die
sich dann so gegenseitig sagen ich habe
neulich einen englischen Comedian gehört
es steht auf der Bühne und spricht eine
Frau im Publikum an und sagt
Entschuldigung für die nächste Nummer
brauche ich eine sehr attraktive Frau
können Sie mir helfen eine zu finden und
alles lacht gut gut dass du oder eben
diesen Satz nicht gesagt hat
Deutschland die Hölle los aber das ist
das das Spiel sozusagen mit mit
halt von Watzlawick ne ich bin das extra
mal rausgezogen aus dem Buch Anleitung
zum unglücklich sein gibt es eine ganz
berühmte Geschichte für nonverbale
Kommunikation du kennst die bestimmt die
Geschichte mit dem Hammer ja ich glaube
die nur in der Version von Ulrich Roski
vorher okay ja es gibt nämlich ein Lied
von Ulrich rossky so ein blöde Bade der
70er die kennst
bis heute nicht das von Borowski oder
Roski von Watzlawik großartig ja darf
ich dich ich lies mal vor ja weil der
Text wirklich sensationell ist und es
ist genau dieses leichtfüßige dass du
gerade angesprochen hast also ein Mann
will ein Bild aufhängen den Nagel hatte
nicht aber den Hammer der Nachbar hatte
einen also beschließt unser Mann hinüber
zu gehen und den auszuborgen doch dann
kommen im Zweifel was wenn der Nachbar
mir den Hammer nicht leiden will gestern
schon hat er mir nur so flüchtig gegrüßt
gut vielleicht war ein Eile aber
vielleicht war die Eile auch nur
vorgetäuscht und vielleicht hat er was
gegen mich und was ich habe immer nichts
angetan der bildet sich da irgendwas ein
und wenn jemand von mir was borgen
wollte ich gebe es ihm sofort also warum
nicht er wie kann man eine Mitmenschen
einen so einfachen Gefallen abschlagen
also Leute wie dieser Kerl vergiften
einem das ganze Leben und dann bildete
sich noch ein ich sage auf ihn
angewiesen bloß weil ein Hammer hat es
reicht's mir wirklich und so stürmt der
hinüber leutet der Nachbar öffnet und
noch bevor er guten Tag sagen kann
schreit in unser Mann an behalten sie
ihren Hammer sie Rüppel
großartige Geschichte ja ehrlich ja bei
Roski geht das darum sich irgendwie
Flasche Bier zu leiden also ungefähr
dieselbe Geschichte
nicht in Frieden leben ja ja also der
der Nachbar wird also immer dämonische
und immer gruseliger in der
vorstellungsfeld das ist und das können
wir ne uns selber sozusagen reinsteigern
uns eine Welt bauen die es in Wahrheit
gar nicht gibt ja das fällt ja auch
unter Reichtum an innerer Welt aber
Reichtum hat auch seine Schattenseiten
und insofern ist wenn wir über Chat GPT
wir wollten ja heute nicht über Jet GPT
sprechen was machen auch nicht aber nur
ganz kurz der Hinweis also das ist ja
genau das also wenn wenn die KI anfängt
Bilder zu erzeugen zu Situationen du
denkst an die Verhaftung von Trump die
es nie gegeben hat ja oder nein
das ist genau das
ist genau das ja ja vielleicht wird die
ganze Zivilisation am Ende nur noch aus
einer Welt bestehen in der sich Realität
und Fiktion mit keinem mit mir
unterscheiden lassen das ist richtig ne
das wäre dann auf dem Planet der Affen
quasi das letzte mögliche Experiment
und wer das gut
es kommt darauf an für den Planeten ja
finde ich das Weiterbestehen der
Menschheit wahrscheinlich nicht aber
Sprache Sprache ist wirklich fasziniert
und und die Tatsache reden wir schon so
lange darüber wie Sprache möglicherweise
entstanden ist und stellen fest
eigentlich wissen wir es gar nicht und
die Tatsache dass das so ist dass wir
bis heute nicht wirklich verstanden
haben und eigentlich immer weniger
verstehen warum uns dieses große Gehirn
gewachsen ist ja viel zu schwer viel zu
viele Energieverbrauch das wird das
alles immer weniger verstehen und dass
das das Leben in Wahrheit oder der
Ursprung unserer Sprache der Ursprung
des Mensch werdens immer noch ein
bisschen rätselhafter wird ist doch
eigentlich total schön in einer Welt in
der irgendwie vermeintlich alles immer
klarer wird oder also ich glaube das
auch hier wieder ich hatte Wusel ja
schon erwähnt ne dieser Satz zutrifft im
doppelten Sinne wir Ihren vorwärts und
das gilt eben auch für unsere Ursprünge
also je größer unsere begriffsmaschine
im Kopf wird und die fantastischer
unsere technischen Erfindungen je mehr
wir uns von unseren ursprünglich
entfernen umso weniger wissen wir
irgendwann noch wer wir sind
und spannt es auch dass wir selbst mit
diesen Mitteln die wir heute zur
Verfügung haben also Archäologen heute
nicht ganz andere Mittel ja das
tatsächlich so ist dass wir uns immer
mehr zum Rätsel werden je länger wir
über uns nachdenken das ist schön finde
ich dass die gute
umgekehrt vor wir werden jedes große
Rätsel der Menschheit gelöst
also abgesehen davon dass ganz
Berufsgruppen dann nicht mehr existieren
würden würde ich doch sagen es ist doch
so schön dass man mit seinem Denken in
der Lage ist immer weiter zu kommen aber
am Ende nie näher dran kommt richtig
schöner Satz Richard ich danke dir
du bleibst jetzt Zoologe meines Herzens
wirklich in diesem Sinne bis bald
tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]